In consistent hashing, the main idea is that the
keys and the nodes map to the same ID space.
So, what we're going to do is, create a metric
space, such as a ring, and we'll put nodes on
this ring, and the idea is that these nodes
each have some ID. Now the keys should also map
to the ID space. So in this case, just
for the sake of example, let's suppose that we have
a six bit ID space, so ID's might range from zero to 63. Now you can see that
the nodes have ID's, and the keys also have
ID's in the same space. A consistent hash function
will assign the nodes, and the keys and identifier
in this space. A hash function such as shah
one might be used to assign these identifiers. In
the case nodes the ID might be a hash
of the IP address. In the case of keys,
the ID might simply just be the hash of a
key. Both of these hash operations create ID's that
are uni-formally distributed in the ID space. The question now
is how to map the key ID's to the
node ID's, so that we know which nodes are responsible
for resolving the look ups for a particular key.
The idea in chord is that a key is stored
at its successor, which is the node with
the next highest ID. So, for example, the key
corresponding to the key ID of 60 would be stored at the node with the node ID
of one. Similarly for the key with the key ID of 54. Forty-two would be stored
at the node with the node ID of 43, 17 at the node with 32, seven and five
at the node with ID of 10, and
so on. Consistent hashing offers the properties of load
balance, because all nodes receive roughly the same
number of keys and flexibility. Because when a node
joins or leaves the network, only a fraction of the keys need to be moved to a
different location. You can actually prove that the solution
is optimal. Meaning that the minimal number of keys
need to be remapped to maintain load balance
when a node joins or leaves the network.